and there's another bill happening in
California
ab665 which allows miners 12 and older
to receive mental health counseling or
therapy without parental consent without
parental consent 12 year olds okay 12
year olds who need if their class was
going to the zoo would need a consent
form but you can talk to a therapist who
you damn well know in the state of
California is going to tell you that you
are trans or two-spirit or you're a cat
or a furry or something else but that's
what they are pushing on the children of
California right now one of the biggest
proponents of this is this guy up in San
Francisco he's a Democrat state senator
named Scott Weiner and here he is
pushing this bill so that courts can
take children from parents yes literally
this bill protects children it makes
children safer it makes children
healthier
and it's unfortunate that this bill like
so many uh has been caught up in this
this
right-wing outrage machine that it's
like every 12 hours they need another uh
another thumb another issue or another
bill uh or another or something that's
completely made up to try to just Stoke
outrage online uh to scare people to
scare parents to to feed this
um just absolutely false moral Panic
that people are running around trying to
steal people's uh children we know that
that there are children who are truly at
risk uh and and and the outrage machine
completely
undermines our efforts to address actual
Children at Risk by making pretend that
all children are somehow being targeted
and that the mental health profession is
targeting them and their teachers are
targeting them and lgbtq people are
targeting them it is outrageous and this
is a good and important bill and I want
to thank you again for moving every
single single thing he said there was
the reverse of the truth and if you
think that that guy with his nail polish
should be in charge of whether some
parent should make a decision over their
child you're crazy and if you live in
California these things are coming for
you if you have children in California
understand right at this moment all the
bill is about is about this divorce
situation so one parent doesn't want to
affirm the gender and one does right
even though they've got that backwards
again you if you were affirming
someone's gender oh you're a 12 year old
boy you're a boy congrats oh you happen
to like pink and you want to go see
Barbie Zippity damn doodah that would be
affirming their gender oh uh you're a
boy and you like pink and Barbie we're
going to chemically castrate you that
doesn't sound very affirming to me but
that nail polished weirdo wants to be in
everyone's house and yes he does want to
take people's children it's just obvious
but you don't have to listen to me just
look what's in the bill
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]